[Music]
three chairs for his majesty the king
hip hip
hip hip
hip hip
while we've all been coming to terms
with the news that queen elizabeth has
died our country has been welcoming a
new king yeah king charles iii i mean i
didn't realize how fast it happens but
as always fyi's got all the info for you
i'm in london and i'll be going inside
there the houses of parliament to find
out what a state funeral is like from
someone who knows all about it
and not far away i'll be talking some of
you who have come to buckingham paris to
pay your respects
and we've got a new king but what
exactly does it mean to be the head of
state if you don't get it my report
should help
[Music]
so so much has happened in the last few
days doesn't it yeah we were just
getting used to our new prime minister
liz truss when just two days after this
picture was taken the queen died
and if you've not watched our special
edition of fyi remembering the queen
then you can still watch it on sky kids
on demand and on our webpage at
first.news forward slash fyi
the sad news meant this happened for the
first time in 70 years
it was a proclamation
what's the proclamation
so basically before they add tv social
media or even radio it seems the way to
announce a new monarch was to shout and
blow trumpets our only lawful and
rightful liege lord
charles iii the tradition brings
together all the past prime ministers
and our new one huddled into a small
room at st james's palace
it's quite strange to seem together like
this yeah and did you notice most of
them all wearing black yeah
well that's the traditional colour when
people are mourning
all sorts of places have changed their
colours too
in australia the sydney opera house
usually looks like this
but last week it looked like this
lots of other buildings did it too from
the tower of london to the empire state
building in new york
they're just some examples of people and
countries showing their thanks to the
queen
another way to pay respect is to file
past the queen's coffin
it was first taken to edinburgh so
scotland could say goodbye
he was then taken to london and thomas
can show us the route it took hey thomas
you there yes i'm on the mao which the
long road that leads to buckingham
palace
the tradition is that any news about the
royal family is displayed on the gates
of buckingham palace
and from the moment the announcement was
made people have been heading here and i
want to find out why they're all
coming i forced my friends to come today
because they're literally living through
history
to me the queen was a very
important and
special person in my life because she
was the queen when i was born she did a
lot for society
and she went to lots of charity events
and doesn't really feel real that she's
gone
so many flowers have been brought there
now
filling green park next to the palace
and they go on forever
mirabelle and yousef are just the latest
to bring their tributes
we should mark who's deaf because
she reigned for 70 years on the phone
the longest in british history and
it's highly unlikely well we'll see that
again in our lifetime what were you
guys's favorite memories of the queen
mine has to be the 2012 olympics
loved that so much the one where she
jumped out the helicopter with james
what
made me laugh when i first saw her i
think it really shows the connection
between her
and the people mine was the
clip with paddington bear where they had
tea and their marmalade sandwich that
one brought a lot of enjoyment and
happiness
paddington and marmalade sandwiches are
everywhere it seems the queen's sense of
humor will not be forgotten and her
starring role at the jubilee is still
making people smile and i think
paddington bear said it perfectly
[Music]
thanks thomas now buckingham palace have
said that there are loads of paddington
bears in green park now so please keep
yours and these marmalade sandwiches at
home hear that paddington
paddings and bears been popping up all
over the place look at this freedom it's
amazing isn't it yeah so it's a picture
of paddington bear made out of shells
and pebbles
it took six hours to plan and four hours
to make
and if you want to share your tribute
with us then head to first.news fyi
[Music]
still to come
i'm inside the palace of westminster to
find out all about the state funeral of
queen elizabeth
but first if you don't get what's going
on this might help
for the last 70 years queen elizabeth is
all we our parents and even our
grandparents have known but now we have
to get used to a king king charles iii
the monarch is also the head of state
and though they're ahead confusingly
that doesn't mean they hold the most
power
i'm going to need a bit of help getting
my head around this and i know just the
person
hello braden hello so how much power
does the british monarch actually have
well the monarch is a really important
figurehead here in the uk if you think
about it the queen's portrait has been
on our coins our banknotes and our
stamps probably for longer than most
people can remember but actually when it
comes to things like making laws it is
largely a ceremonial role for example
the monarch every week has a private
meeting with the prime minister but it's
not the monarch's responsibility to tell
the prime minister what to do they are
there to advise encourage and to warn
they have that very important role as
well of giving out honours to people
who've been doing good work up and down
the country and carrying out visits to
shine a light on important community
projects now the monarch is also
commander in chief of the armed forces
but it doesn't mean it's their
responsibility to start wars that comes
down to the uk government which of
course is voted for by uk adults as part
of our democracy well thank you very
much
okay so i get all of that but what i'm
really scratching your head about is how
all this royal family stuff even started
so i'm gonna take us back in time for a
quick history lesson
you've heard of 1066 right that was the
year the french invaded england in what
was called the norman conquest having
won the battle this guy william the
conqueror was made king of england even
though he could hardly speak any english
since then there have been loads of
battles over who has control of the
throne and some untimely deaths so lots
of different kings and queens some of my
favorites are richard ii who was only 10
when he was crowned imagine that
henry viii who had six wives
and elizabeth the first who fought off
an attempt to overthrow her when the
spanish armada sailed towards england
queen elizabeth ii automatically became
queen as soon as her father died her
coronation took place a year later in
1953.
now she has died charles as her first
son automatically becomes king
so the rules are that to become our head
of state you have to be born into the
royal family you also have to be
christian because ever since the reign
of henry viii part of the role is to be
the defender of the faith
the british monarch is the supreme
governor of the church of england but
they also recognise and celebrate other
faiths
as for other countries well they all
have their own systems to decide who
becomes their head of state for example
in saudi arabia king salman bin abdul
aziz has absolute power and there's
never been a national election
and in countries like the usa brazil and
nigeria the head of state is the
president elected by the people with
power to run the country and make new
laws
the system here in the uk is not without
its critics who say it's outdated and
too expensive but others argue that we
really benefit from having the monarchy
it allows the politicians to get on with
running the country without too many
distractions and having a royal family
with all its traditions makes the uk
stand out in the world
monday the whole world will be watching
london as we say goodbye to queen
elizabeth
i've heard that even the president of
the united states joe biden is coming
also the leaders of australia new
zealand and canada however these
countries are a little bit different
because the queen is also their head of
state the queen is also on their money
so this is a 20 canadian note
get you your international money
so yeah
money and stamps they're gonna change so
that they can have king charles's face
on it
now we've checked with the royal mail
and it's officially down to the king to
decide whether he wants his left side or
his right side of his face on the stamp
whichever side he thinks he looks best
in
but with money the royal mint tells us
that tradition is that the direction the
monarch faces changes each time
so expect for king charles to be looking
the other way that's a good point and
finally did you see this oh yeah so when
you become a cub or a brownie you have
to make a promise to the queen so let me
guess these are the first people to make
a promise of the king that's it now it
takes a bit of getting used to to say
king charles however he's been preparing
for his job all his life
when he was my age he knew he was going
to be king
he's 73 years old now and he spent his
life taking an interest in all sorts of
subjects
he's even got a species of frog named
after him
he set up a charity called the prince's
trust which helps young people
but perhaps he's most well known for
being one of the first important figures
to stand up for the climate
last year he introduced a sky kids
documentary about the impact of climate
change on young people called in your
hands i'm delighted that in this film
we'll be hearing from six young climate
activists from six different continents
though he still cares about the planet
he's already announced that he's focused
on the job of being king yeah and his
next job as king is to lead the state
funeral so we're catching up with
scarlet who's inside the houses of
parliament
hey scarlett where are you i'm in a part
of the building called speaker's house
it's right near westminster hall the
building where the queen is lying in
state the coffin arrived here on
wednesday and i was outside watching it
[Music]
the new king and the royal family
followed in procession from buckingham
palace
thomas was in the crowd too as it
traveled along the mall
the coffin was draped in the royal
standard flag placed on top was the
crown worn by the queen at her
coronation in 1953
seeing the procession was an honor
to be here and watch it it was really
special to see
a moment in history like that
because it was so busy i ended up here
in hyde park watching on these screens
how does it feel being able to be here
today really special because we get to
see the last moments that we can see
with the queen
i feel like the time right now is when
it actually feels real when you're
seeing the whole royal family marching
and the gunshots being fired and it
feels like time has stopped
the coffin will remain at westminster
hall until the funeral takes place
and then a procession will take the
coffin to westminster abbey where at 11
a.m the state funeral service will take
place and be shown on tv
the day will be a bank holiday so we'll
be off school the last time there was a
state funeral for a monarch was in 1952
for king george vi
so this is the first time we'll see one
so what's it going to be like welcome to
speaker's encouragement
i've come to meet someone who can help
me this is trisha the speaker's chaplain
her job is to say the prayers in the
house of commons but she also works at
westminster abbey where the state
funeral will take place so what is a
funeral so obviously when someone we
really love dies it's a time of sadness
but also all kinds of feelings
and a funeral is really an opportunity
for people to come together to be with
one another to remember the person that
they've loved what happens at a funeral
well in a christian funeral like the one
we're about to see typically there'd be
candles lit those symbolize hope there'd
be music and lots of it there'd be lots
of words said there'd also be silence
and there'd be prayers said of course
funerals are an important time for
families to mourn so william harry and
the rest of the family will be there
but because this is a funeral for a
monarch this service is also for the
whole country so this is a state funeral
will it be any different there'll be a
couple of thousands in the abbey but
beyond that there could be billions
around the world watching listening in
so it really is one of those unique
moments in our world history actually so
what will you be doing on monday yeah so
on monday i'll be in the abbey i'll be
there at the service part of the clergy
team who are serving in the service
as the queen's funeral comes to an end
we are all invited to join in a national
two-minute silence it's another way we
can show our respect
thanks scarlett so where are you now
well i've left the houses of parliament
and this is the queue of people waiting
to foul past the queen's coffin they've
been here for ages and it just shows how
much the queen meant to so many people
it was very last minute but last night
we decided that we thought we'd pay our
respects to the queen and come over how
does it make you feel being here today
it's a once in a lifetime opportunity
and it's really great to be here
thanks scarlett and here's thomas
i've escaped the crowds and the day
after the funeral the period of national
mourning will be finished and flags like
this one will fly at the top of the pole
again
and after talking to lots of you there's
one thing for sure
we'll never forget the queen
well that's it from us today but we can
leave you with some of your thoughts
about the queen
bye
she was here the first 13 years of my
life so it's really sad that she's gone
she
was the longest reigning monarch and
she also was kind to animals
she was probably the last female monarch
i'm going to be alive to see
this is a message to king charles sorry
for the loss of your mother and long
live king child survived
[Music]
you